dónde
[Música]
todo
qué es lo que acaba de hacer mediante
este instrumento electrónico creado por
mí que llamo el cubo explorer a un
paisaje sonoro un mundo sonoro el cubo
responde a mi movimiento de izquierda a
derecha adelante hacia atrás en la
velocidad que lo muevo de esta misma
forma yo respondo a lo que el cubo me da
buscando esos sweet spots esos puntos
dulces que para mi criterio tienen
carácter y que son emotivos que me hacen
sentir algo es como explorar este cuadro
de vincent van gogh poder entrar en el
hacerlo real y pasearse por los
diferentes colores y texturas y
encontrar los puntos que de alguna forma
hacen sentir algo mírenlo y exploren lo
donde encuentran esos puntos dulces
[Música]
así como un violinista puede transmitir
no solo sus emociones pero las del mismo
compositor que escribió la pieza a
través de su movimiento y la interacción
con su instrumento yo intento hacer lo
mismo con mi instrumento
una pregunta que me he hecho muchas
veces y que muchas personas me han hecho
es esto música mi respuesta es no
importa lo que quiero lograr como muchos
muchos sin decir todos es poder expresar
mis emociones a través del sonido es ser
que ustedes puedan vivir sus propias
emociones en el momento a través de lo
que yo les presento
mis pasiones son el sonido y la
tecnología lo que yo quiero compartir es
que el movimiento la tecnología y el
sonido son capaces de crear una
experiencia sónica musical con el
potencial de exaltar emociones de una
forma muy humana trata de hacer esto a
través del instrumento el cubo pero
también a través de los sonidos que
escoge explorar y de cómo decidió
explorar los vivimos en una época donde
la tecnología y notablemente se vuelve
parte esencial de nuestras vidas yo lo
acepto con manos abiertas la exploró con
la idea de que ya no interceda entre mí
y mis ideas sino que las apoye y me
dejen crear algo que puede tener la
misma o más de expresión que un
instrumento tradicional
no llegamos un momento en la historia de
la tecnología de instrumentos musicales
electrónicos ya que es muy poco conocida
y es un pilar importantísimo para
elaboración de mis ideas y las ideas de
muchos grandes compositores en música
electrónica
hoy en día
leon término científico ruso en 1919
popularizó su inventó el término gran
instrumento que demuestra las
posibilidades de expresión humana a base
de la tecnología junto con movimiento
movimiento aquí vemos a charly driver en
el término
[Música]
fritz train en 1929 inventó el trato
unión
aquí vamos a ver el intérprete con alias
ghost man y demostrando la demostrando
la posible expresividad de este
instrumento a través de tecnología
movimiento y sonido
[Música]
al final de los años 60 es uno de los
grandes inventores de instrumentos
electrónicos robert mutt se basó en
estas ideas ya mencionadas y en otras y
creó los primeros sintetizadores que
eran económicamente viables los
instrumentos nook se popularizaron entre
varios géneros y rápidamente se
convirtieron en un estándar continuó su
legado y esta compañía sigue viva hasta
ahora los instrumentos nook se han
diversificado en varios modelos desde
tamaños pequeños como una laptop o
modelos grandes como el tamaño de esta
mesa han dado accesibilidad a
sonoridades electrónicas a mucha gente
inclusive muy hoy en día sigue
produciendo el término de lyon término
aquí pueden apreciar esto con sus
ancianos presentando una obra suya en un
sistema 55
[Música]
pasemos a hablar sobre mentes brillantes
en el mundo de la música electrónica
karlheinz stockhausen una mente
definitivamente adelantada décadas a su
tiempo cuál es su mayor influencia hacia
mí en cómo pensaba en el sonido en los
setentas está causen dio una serie de
conferencias tituladas por criterios
electronic music es cuatro criterios de
la música electrónica en una de sus
conferencias se pregunta qué pasa si
todo podríamos tomar las novena sinfonía
de beethoven y comprimir la en el tiempo
de tal forma que sólo dure un segundo es
el segundo de la sinfonía de beethoven
tendría un carácter un timbre especial
que le haría ser la sinfonía de
beethoven a diferencia de cualquier
música de otro estilo que sería
comprimida en un segundo en esa época no
se podía lograr eso tecnológicamente ese
sobrero ni idea de él hoy si se puede
lograr y aquí está la novena sinfonía en
cinco segundos y en un segundo
[Música]
dieron río música francés espacialmente
reconocido por ser el creador de música
concreta android es una de las primeras
personas en tomar sonidos pregrabados o
él mismo los grababa en cintas sonidos
de ambientes de pájaros de ríos de
máquinas máquinas inclusive de música
mismo y contar los de formas creativas
en el estudio para crear piezas con
sonoridades muy distintas de las
tradicionales otra gran mente que me
inspira a la exploración de sonido
john cage reconocido compositor por
crear el concepto de chance music una de
sus piezas williams mix gates tomó
varias cintas magnéticas con una
variedad de grabaciones las cortó en
muchos pedazos las lanzó al piso y
después aleatoriamente las volvió a
pegar uno por uno hasta que la cinta
podría volver a ser reproducida kate es
un genio de concepto y esto influye
mucho empezar en el concepto de música y
las ideas que uno quiere explorar aquí
podemos echar un poquito de williams mix
como se une toda esta historia quien
heredaron esto no está ni cerca de todo
lo que ha habido pero da una idea básica
cómo se une todo esto en lo que se les
estoy presentando hoy cada invento y
cada idea es una parte importante que se
relaciona de alguna forma con la
tecnología el movimiento y el sonido y
estos tres elementos son mis bases para
poder crear y explorar instrumentos
electrónicos y piezas musicales que
pueden de alguna forma humanizar la
tecnología y gracias a esta misma
tecnología que nos permiten romper
barreras tradicionales ejemplo un piano
a través de sus mecanismos de
construcción crea una forma de poder
transformar el movimiento del ente del
intérprete en sonido esta se basa en
teclas cada tecla representa un tono
encontrado en la música tradicional
occidental y de la forma del piano y su
acústica en sus cuerdas y su resonancia
que da un sonido de un piano no todos
los pianos suenan exactamente iguales
pero podemos claramente reconocer un
piano cuando oímos un sonido de un piano
[Música]
lo mismo sucede con instrumentos
tradicionales y estamos significa que no
son capaces de una tremenda expresividad
musical al contrario convertirse en un
maestro intérprete de un instrumento
lleva a una forma inmensa de
expresividad sin embargo cada
instrumento trabajaba sus límites debido
a la construcción física con violines un
violín un saxofón es un saxofón un piano
es un piano
y en este caso que es el cubo
hacemos con movimiento y como también
tiene sus restricciones debido a su
construcción física por ejemplo en un
piano yo puedo saltar de un tono bajo a
un tono alto instantáneamente sin pasar
por todos los tonos intermedios con él
como no puedo tengo que viajar de un
sonido a otro y pasar por todos los
sonidos intermedios sin embargo esta
característica es algo que lo hace
interesante algo que le diferencia de
algunos instrumentos tradicionales
justamente por el hecho de que no puedo
saltar de un tono a otro y es así como
puedo representar el movimiento del
intérprete de una forma muy distinta a
un instrumento tradicional tecnología la
tecnología me permite hacer con el cubo
justamente lo que sería difícil en un
instrumento tradicional esta tecnología
está construido por un microprocesador
muy poderoso que existe hoy en día
llamado art window y es accesible para
cualquier persona que tenga motivación
no tienen que saber programar pueden
usarlo mediante arduino
yo puedo programar al cubo para que haga
lo que yo quiera yo podría hacer que se
prendan y se apaguen las luces de este
teatro con el cubo yo podría hacerle el
control remoto para la presentación
si yo quiero las posibilidades son
extensas pero mi enfoque artístico es en
la música y en el sonido con el cubo
diseño para explorar música y sonido
sonido este es uno de los factores más
importantes para mí qué tipo de sonido
crea el cubo la respuesta es el que yo
quiera como dije anteriormente un piano
es un piano que es del cubo nuevamente
lo que yo quiera yo puedo con el cubo
podéis lograr un sonido que puede ser
cualquier sonido que puede ser grabado
puede ser un piano puede ser un violín
puede ser un bombo andino puede ser el
sonido de un río en el oriente
nuevamente las posibilidades son
extensas tan extensas que yo mismo tengo
me tengo que preguntar que quiero
explorar sónicamente con el cubo la idea
de poder convertirlo en un piano no me
atrae porque pianos ya hay lo que sí me
atrae es poder explorar mezclas de
varios sonidos que me den un lienzo el
que yo pueda ir pintando como por
ejemplo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eso es por ejemplo una grabación de un
cello
que quiero lograr con todo esto que
quiero lograr con mi exploración de
sonido en base a nuevos instrumentos
electrónicos la primera razón quiero
poder compartir mis emociones como
cualquier músico lo hace si a base de lo
que ustedes han escuchado en estos
últimos minutos han sentido algo algo
especial entonces estoy logrando lo que
yo quiero lograr lo importante para mí
es que se haga a través de sonoridades y
medios de expresión de tecnologías
modernas como el cubo no son
tradicionales
hablemos nuevamente de tecnología y
movimiento existen tantos tipos de
instrumentos acústicos en este mundo
instrumentos originales de diferentes
culturas instrumentos tradicionales del
occidente instrumentos orientales es
increíble cuánto hay no existen también
muchos instrumentos que mezclan lo
acústico electrónico como por ejemplo la
guitarra eléctrica y los órganos
ambos cuales inicialmente tuvieron
resistencia yo son tan normales como un
violín estos instrumentos siguen siendo
parte importante de la música y se los
uso igual o más que se los usaba antes y
son capaces de alta expresividad
especialmente si el intérprete se vuelve
un maestro que queda por explorar
entonces para mí los instrumentos
electrónicos estos que no dependen de la
acústica la cual es reemplazada por el
electrónico la meta es poder lograr un
mismo grado de expresividad que un
instrumento tradicional prueba dando
explorando lo que la tecnología me puede
dar
hablemos otra vez un rato de sonido hay
tanto sonido hermoso en nuestro
alrededor todos los días y la mayoría de
nosotros no paramos un momento para
prestar atención john cage decía no
existe tal cosa como un espacio vacío o
un tiempo vacío siempre hay algo que ver
algo que escuchar es más tratemos como
mejor podamos de crear silencio y no
podremos en este momento voy a dejar de
hablar y quiero que todos aprecien el
sonido se fije en su sonido que viene
por detrás suyo por delante por los
lados
quiero que traten de internalizar el
sonido y apreciarlo por lo que es por
como cambia por lo que los hace sentir
ese celular estuvo excelente escucharon
fue como una composición en sí y eso es
eso es lo que john cage hizo en su
famosa obra 433 pieza en la que el
pianista se sienta en un piano pianistas
famosísimos se sienta en el piano y por
4 minutos y 33 segundos no tocan
absolutamente nada
qué pasa cuando juntamos todos estos
elementos ese es mi mundo eso es lo que
yo exploro y lo que quiero seguir
explorando todo con el fin de poder
hacer instrumentos intuitivos que
exploren sus realidades frescas y que la
tecnología ya no interceda sino que
simplemente se vuelva algo completamente
invisible así como un violinista toca su
violín y un artista pinta su cuadro
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]